has been very supportive and for whom I
owe my thanks
having spent many many years either near
in or under the water in pool Harbor I
am acutely aware of the area's sensitive
environment both on land and under the
sea
to that end I am very concerned at this
bill which is potentially catastrophic
and let's not forget that many thousands
of humans who enjoy the harbor
especially in the Sun
I've been assured this morning that the
spill is not as serious as first thought
the majority of the fluid that leaked
from underground pipeline was contained
yesterday as my writing a friend has
said however a thin Sheen of oil did
escape the Booms that were put in place
and a handful of birds have been found
today covered in oil massively that
number remains low the effect on the
marine environment is unknown
having spoken to paremco this morning
they estimate that nearly 5 000 liters
of fluid leaked from the pipeline the
fluid is 15 crude oil 85 percent water
the leaking underground pipe is located
in a very sensitive marshy low-lying
area in the south of the harbor
the contamination was exacerbated by a
high tide and a river that runs through
the site into the Hub
a large operation to combat The Spill
using helicopters drones vessel and
onshore patrols continues today
specialist cleanup companies have been
called in to give advice and that
operation will start as soon as possible
on that note can I ask by right on my
friend to ensure that it is apparent the
regulator carries out a full
investigation into why the leak occurred
and once identified ensures any repairs
are done to the highest standard also
that she will seek Assurance from
parenko that the rest of their network
is being properly maintained and checked
we do not want this to happen ever again
administer
I thank him for his question and indeed
for the uh
assiduousness with which he has actually
dealt with this uh incident which as he
has highlighted is an extremely
important nature and Wildlife Area
recognized across the world and a very
sensitive site and I like to give him
absolute assurances that a full
investigation is underway it's critical
that the investigation is carried out uh
so that we got the full details of what
occurred exactly where the leak was
exactly which bit of pipeline it was and
then the full detail of how to react and
what needs to be done in terms of
cleanup and so forth in future can be
put together and carried out the pipe
has been shut off and depressurized to
prevent any further discharges and I
give him absolute assurances that I as
the minister will be following this very
closely to assure or that all the
correct procedures and the right
investigation which can then inform what
we do in future in terms of the
regulation and The Regulators is all
carried out Shannon Minister Ruth Young
yeah thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
for granting this urgent question and I
thank the member for South Dorset for
bringing it to the chamber today in one
way it's really good to not be talking
about sewage discharges today but this
oil spill is far too serious a matter to
make political points so therefore I
will confine my limited time to
highlight the worries and concerns of
local people and businesses in the pool
area
I realize it's still early days in terms
of the investigation which I do hope
will be thorough and Speedy and that any
lessons to be learned will be published
and acted upon as quickly as possible we
don't want this to happen again and
blight another Coastal Community
so come the minister enlarge on her
previous responses and in particular can
she outline what work the department and
the environment agency are undertaking
together to address the impact this
incident could have on the local
population and environment endorse it
not just in the site but in the
surrounding area and what is the
government doing to assess the impact on
small businesses which rely on the
Harbor for trade and what support will
be made available to them
and will the minister confirm that the
relevant agencies will have the full
support they need to to address his
incident including Manpower and finally
Mr Speaker the pool Harbor
commissioner's latest oil spill
contingency plan appears to be dated
July 2021 although the review date was
August 2022 so can the minister confirm
if this is indeed the latest version if
the stated review was carried out in
2022 and if so what was the outcome
uh I thank her for that and uh for
realizing the importance of this and
focusing just about this particular
incident uh we are taking it extremely
seriously the investigation is underway
all of the right Protocols are in place
and that's why the pool Harbor
Commissioners have activated their
emergency oil spill response plan and
that's why specialist oil spill
companies are assisting with the
operation uh the Dorset local resilience
Forum has already set up and convened
its strategic coordination group with
all the relative relevant bodies that
have take part in that which includes
the Commissioners themselves but also
the EA and the marine coastal agency
coast guards agency and they are all uh
inputting into this as to our Natural
England who have set up their Southwest
environment team to do their work all of
which will feed in to giving us the
details that we need to make sure the
full measures are taken and we can
understand exactly what has occurred
here I would like to give her assurances
that the harbor remains open as usual
the Ferry services working the local
beaches are open although as a
precaution the public have been told to
avoid using the water for recreational
purposes
in pool Harbor until further updates are
available it's Robertson can I fully
support my honorable friend member for
that Dorset in the comments that he's
made of course the harbor Commissioners
have planned for this sort of thing over
the years and they're constantly
updating their plans the latest
information is that 60 to 70 percent of
the oil on the surface yesterday has
actually been reduced so we're well on
top of the situation a couple of points
clearly this has an impact on public
confidence which is why we need an
inquiry just to look at it this is a
mature field that which has been
reducing for over 40 years and it may be
that some of the pipes do need replacing
and secondly there are fishermen and a
number of companies in pool Harbor who
generate seafood and Export it to France
and if there is any temporary suspension
of their ability to do that there may be
a question of compensation and I and my
colleagues may wish to be talking to the
Fishers Minister on that
okay I thank him for that and also for
the work that he has also been doing on
this and he's absolutely right it is
about giving assurances which is why
it's so critical that this investigation
is undertaken fully and in uh all of the
right way as he said actually this um
this oil field has been worked since
1979 and this is the first incident of
really any kind like this that has
occurred but it has to be dealt with uh
extremely seriously and I believe it is
being uh with all of the rights teams uh
being brought to bear to give us the
information we need and the short the
assurances that we need going forward
and actually the the UK Health Security
Agency
um uh people people should follow their
advice in terms of any kind of advice in
terms of seafood and eating seafood and
of course
um I will relate to the Fisheries
Minister that he will be in touch if
necessary
Harbor is nature Rich from the on bird
sanctuary 2 to ground Sea Island and in
bearing that in mind and in the light of
the age of the infrastructure can she
say when the infrastructure was last
examined for its compliance with safety
to avoid such uh an incident as we have
seen over the last couple of days
well yes I agree it is a really
wonderful and sensitive Wildlife site
really famous for its incredible Birds
its turns its other sets uh even its
goals even its red squirrels on Brown
Sea Island and there's a full
um regime of
um run tree the regulator for checking
uh the pipe work and so forth but all of
this will be looked at all of the
records and the maintenance records will
be looked at in the investigation
yeah the deputy speaker tourism is of
course an important part of the County's
economy and public confidence in using
water for recreational purposes is
pivotal to that offer allowing people
then visit the countryside you know in
in north dorses and elsewhere in the
county because my honorable friend tell
us what further work her agencies will
be doing in order to monitor sea bathing
quality going forward and watch her
department and the uh and the department
for two of the minister for tourism can
do in order to work with Dorset Council
and others in order to ensure that
Dorset is safe to swim in and visit is a
message which was received across the
country
thank you and I thank him for that and
for uh mentioning tourism and he's
absolutely right it's a phenomenal um uh
part of our tourism offer in this
country both for locals but also for
people coming from abroad and that's why
the investigation is so important that's
why the messaging is so important and
actually uh the public must adhere to
the UK health and Security Agency
guidance at the moment the local
resilience Forum have not issued any um
any concerns about the impact on tourism
but of course this will be something
that will be
um will be kept uh under guidance but
actually he should take uh confidence in
the fact that Natural England have set
up that standing environment group or
the environmental ngos are involved the
rspb actually Mr Speaker are already
saying that they believe this is being
well handled well dealt with we don't
want any uh Wildlife to be impacted so
every precaution needs to be taken but
in fact uh what I've heard is just two
seabirds so far have uh been found with
all on them and they've been carefully
washed off I've witnessed this myself
when I was an environment reporter uh
and and it's a it's a fantastic process
but we need to make sure we know fully
what's happening in the investigation so
that we can make sure that there are not
any adverse impacts on tourism which is
such an important industry to this
country
I thank the minister for her diligent
approach and response to this very
troubling occurrence and congratulate
The Honorable member for bringing this
the attention of the whole house she
will agree with me I'm sure that not
only is there an ecological price to pay
for this spillage there'll also be an
impact has been already mentioned on the
potential bathing water status of pool
Harbor I wonder if you'll agree with me
that bathing water status is a very
important tool in ratcheting up water
quality both offshore on our Coast but
in our rivers and lakes as well and I
wonder if you would reflect on the fact
only 10 percent of the applications for
bathing water status for our rivers and
lakes and coastal areas last year were
accepted in my own constituency coniston
water and the river Kent were turned
down despite having many many more
bathers than some rivers that were
accepted which he agreed that
consistency is important if we're going
to keep our waterways free of oil and
sewage in which you look again at these
at these applications that were turned
down
uh thank you Mr Speaker but
um with respect to also to the shadow
Minister who is sticking to the subject
of this urgent question which is so
important I would say that was somewhat
irrelevant Mr Speaker and I would also
say that our our bathing water uh oh
well over
um 70 is excellent and if you add go
down excellent together it's it's over
90 percent
Mr Speaker as a number of members have
pointed out not least uh honorable
friend who secured this important
question the Dorset Coast forms part of
an incredibly fragile ecosystem across
much of the South Coast part of its
fragility and uniqueness is that it's
fed by a network of chalk streams 80 of
the world's chalk streams are in our
part of the the world in January the
river Anton which flows through my
constituency so a not dissimilar spill
30 000 liters of oil into the to the
river uh I wanted to commend the
environment agency on their Swift
response they tell me they've recovered
about 17 000 liters and and workers
underway to recover the rest however uh
while there will obviously be an
investigation into the cause of The
Spill and if there is culpability that
will be um applied and there may well be
consequences I wanted to understand for
the minister where the accountability
and the transparency lies with the
environment agency for the conduct of
that investigation in a police
environment where an investigation takes
place we have a police and crime
Commission on panel of accountability
for the police for the work that they do
with the environment agency the system
is more opaque how can my constituency
have a constituents have confidence
um that uh an investigation is conducted
with alacrity and if there is
culpability it's applied appropriately
Minister thank you
um I I can assure
that's why
it's so important
information has to
also we need to be careful about
spreading
fears about what exactly the pollutant
was that's why the investigation has to
take place and why the exact makeup of
that pollutant needs to be fully uh
known and then the EA of course would
investigate if if there was enough
evidence to suggest that potentially a
crime had been committed and if a crime
has been committed and the due process
is followed of course fines are possible
under the EA so I want to give him those
assurances Karen McCarthy thank you Mr
Speaker obviously the priority is to
make sure that this incident is cleaned
up but what lessons will the government
learn about the wisdom of allowing
future drillion in environmentally
important sites I'm thinking
particularly the rose bank site going
through a marine protected area we need
to learn lessons when incidents like
this happen can the minister assure me
that she'll be speaking to her
colleagues
I thank you for that and of course I
would be the first minister to say we
need assurances to look after our
wonderful sensitive environmental sites
but actually this oil field has been
worked since 1979 as far as I understand
it it's the largest onshore oil field in
Europe and so whilst this investigation
has to take place we have to find out
what happened and if there's anything
needs needs uh correcting it that needs
to be done but uh I don't think we
should be um spreading fear about this
particular operation or others like it
they're just an important part of our
energy makeup relan Lucas thank you Mr
Speaker pool Harbor is indeed a Haven
for wildlife and home to rare species so
this is incredibly saddening the
minister says that she wants to ensure
This Disaster isn't repeated but she
must know that wherever there is
drilling there is some spilling a
staggering 721 oil spills in the North
Sea alone over the last three years just
last month the planning inspector had
overturned where Sussex County council's
refusal of permission for more testing
for Shale oil reserves in Balcom beneath
the high wheeled area of outstanding
natural beauty given the huge risks to
the natural world when things go wrong
will she speak to the Secretary of State
for leveling up and ask him to review
this decision yeah
it's all about balance it's really
important that we protect our natural
environment particularly in areas as
precious as the pool Harbor area because
that's as important to our economy as
the oil it's all about balance and it's
all about ensuring that this
investigation is correctly carried out
as swiftly as possible and anything that
needs to be put in place to to it to
enhance the Environmental Protections
and measures that we have must be put in
place and I would say that for any other
similar project Ben Bradshaw I was a
little bit surprised Mr Speaker that the
minister could not answer my honorable
friend the member for York's question
about who was responsible for regulating
this facility maybe she's got the answer
there on a piece of paper regulating
this facility and when it was last
inspected if she doesn't know and can't
get the answer from officials before the
end of this question time perhaps you
put a written statement in the house
Minister I thank him for that but I did
actually say that uh all of all of those
records will be assessed the maintenance
records and dates will be assessed uh if
he wants me to write to him about that
when we know the exact detail I will
give him insurance that we will do that
but all of that detail is absolutely
critical to the investigation
can I thank the minister very much for
her diligence and for a clear commitment
to address they always spell a pill when
we had a spill in one of our local
Rivers back home environmental work was
carried out immediately to replenish the
wildlife with local conservation bodies
I can the minister confirm that Nutter
England and EA has the expertise to say
that very gracefully and very
respectfully house expertise in the
conservation efforts including the
outstanding poll wildfires Association
who are active and in that area are can
undertake not only to Simply remove the
oil itself but also to restore as soon
as possible the echo balance thank you
sure
I can for
them raising the
ish environment and
already that standing environment group
has been set up by Natural England
that's in addition to the investigation
that's underway they've brought in the
environmental route to have a great deal
of knowledge in the area and run many of
the wonderful nature reserves there and
including the rspb who were really doing
their bit as well and we've actually got
a cleanup team Shoreline cleanup team
out right now uh both on onshore and in
boats Gathering data so that we know
exactly what's happening all of that
will be fed into the investigation
that completes the Urgent question will
come to the statement I'd be